super intriguing name for it too
dark matter or dark energy it's super
heavy metal sounding
like a metal band but you know
scientists sometimes have the weirdest
ways of naming things i mean
really like like dark matter is
literally like i have no idea
it's really where the name came off of
dark you know the old idea i mentioned
quark
right uh it was like what sort of name
is that well it's actually a direct
quote from
a book by james joyce called finnegan's
wake and the person who developed the
theory
by the name of mary gall man he just
liked the phrase
from you know uh i come in the exact
quote but the word quark appears and
he's like oh i like that so
you know just tell that idea so the we
have some weird names but
yeah um in essence the dark simply means
you don't know we have no idea so what
does that mean for
for us if the universe is
ever expanding versus going back in
directly not much so um
there is um in essence
it's speeding up but what that means
in the life of the universe let's talk
about that
but eventually all that energy is going
to go it's going to dissipate so
um in in
the long scheme of things the universe
if it continues the way it does will
eventually die
out all the stars will stop burning they
will run out of their fuels
you'll have stars going to black holes
there'll be anything left
and the end and other black bodies and
in essence
it's just dark dark matter is left over
er
dark matter and other matter as well but
it won't be
but okay dark matter in a sense we just
talked about but also
any real matter the normal matter will
be dark in that sort of it won't release
radiation it won't have light anymore so
it will just go
black now uh terrifying
it's terrifying but we're talking about
something that's going to occur
in over the trillions
of trillions of years here we're not
talking about something
anytime immediate i think
in terms of humanity our more immediate
pressing problem
in an astronomical sense is the death of
our own son
so our death of our own son is probably
going to occur
in about well you know give or take
maybe
three to four billion years time now
people go oh my goodness that's a
problem but you know
life has existed on the earth for only
about
you know two billion years and i'm
talking about primordial life
right the earth itself has only existed
for four and a half billion years
and humanity as we know it we're only
dealing with a few
you know a hundred thousand years and so
forth you know osteopathicus
which is one early human ancestors so to
speak
you know two million years ago and that
is one
you know one and uh you know as fraction
of the life of the earth so you and i
won't have any problems with their sun
and i think we have far more issues of
uh humanity destroying itself through
other means
so you know we say it's terrifying but
for you and i right here it has really
no real impact at all
but i guess it's again about science
saying look we'd like to know how this
works we know what's what's the braces
behind it you know um it's not about
as i said to you before about learning
for the sake of what can we get out of
it
it's about understanding our place in
the universe you know
um how it works you know that's driven
humanity
from day one that we want a better
understanding of the world we live in
and our place in it and science
is basically that it's about
understanding who
we are and what's our place in our
universe and how it all works and how it
fits
and allowing our mind to go wow this is
an amazing place
you know and and even more amazing when
we work of some of the details of how it
works whether it's
in the really small which is you know
that quantum world which is what cern
discovers
or the really big where we look at
astronomers and cosmologists and say how
the universe works
and interestingly cern is dealing with
both because they're wanting to
understand the
nature of matter at the quantum level
but also understanding dark matter to
say look that gives us understanding of
our
cosmos as well you know it's about the
search for meaning and the search for
understanding
and that's really what science is um
it's
saying why does it work this way it's
back to our very first thing i said
you know scientists are basically
people who haven't lost that sense of
why is that daddy
why isn't that mummy no they've stuck
with that
and they've um you know
taken that into their field and worked
out why
you know and if we ended up developing
these technologies to
benefit mankind benefited humanity and
so forth
fantastic but that's not why they do it
they do it because i want to know why
i want to know you know and they're
excited by the discoveries that they
make in the process
that's amazing man well hey i'm i'm a
little bit crunched for time today we
had to cut it to about an hour and 15
minutes
but um i really appreciate you doing
this i want to do a follow-up down the
road for sure where we can sit here for
a couple hours and go through some stuff
um what was your last name your first
name is paul
paul my last name is loyan lwyen um
and so yeah um how can you find you
people listening to this how can they
find you on youtube and
yeah so whatever yeah so
my my tags i think is physics high
so uh in youtube you'll find me there uh
facebook physics hi twitter physics hi
um i i have instagram and physics high
though i haven't used it as much
but basically and then i have a website
as well which is funny enough
www.physicshire.com
so that's the way to find me and like i
said if you go there
you'll see a lot of sort of straight
physics content
but um i hope that people continue to
follow me because i'm hoping to
you know do more general stuff in terms
over time as well um i'm a full-time
teacher so it's a real balancing act
i'd love to be able to get enough
subscribers that i can
you know maybe go part-time teaching and
so forth and to put more time in my
youtube and communication of science
because that's what i really am
passionate about communicating science
and physics uh but um you know yeah it's
it's that's critical that's critical not
just understanding it but i mean anyone
can
not anyone but it's one thing to
understand it
and and have the knowledge it's another
thing to be able to communicate that
to the world and to everybody else
that's that's
just as important as having the
information totally totally totally
totally i mean i think um one of the
things i always
i i strive towards and i know i'm not
saying i get it but i love it when i
hear a student say
i really love physics and why do you
love physics because i had a teacher who
really
was passionate and communicated that
passion towards me
and you know and i i'm always excited by
the fact that people are switched on
science because
someone took the time to communicate it
effectively to them
and as a result you know they um
were um drove home can i give you a
little story that i picked up at soon
something really um that drives that
particular point
home i uh met up with a guy named david
fish and maybe he watches this as well
he's actually
a teacher consultant for the perimeter
institute which is a
physics institute based in toronto
canada and
uh he gave some of the presentations
that we had at cern
and he shared about a student when he
was in teaching about a student he said
um was a little bit lost didn't know
what to do
and he just encouraged her and said you
know what i think
you should look do a bit of a research
and uh look into what dark matter is and
shooting introduces dark matter here
and she went okay and so she did that
and
it switched life on and as a result she
did a physics degree
and as a result um of the physics degree
she decided to go into particle physics
and as a result of particle physics she
got a position
at cern and um and
as a result you know basically was in
the team for the particle detectors from
there
now i'm talk a day after he presented
that i'm sitting
at lunch in cern with dave next to me
and he's talking to this girl on the
other side and the girl said to me
she was talking to dave and she said you
know i've really been passionate about
this atlas experiment involved
but i think i might go to this other
project over here at cern and so forth
and all of a sudden the penny dropped
the girl that i was talking to across me
was the girl that i
he actually had just switched on with
dark matter when she was in high school
you know so here's this girl who's gone
from this
encouragement to do dark matter because
one teacher took the time to just
invest some time into her and now she
was doing great things at cern she was
just not doing a phd student
she was now employed full time at cern
and looking for other ways to in
you know to explore science and and i
think that's the key you know you ignite
a passion you know with knowledge
and explore it yes it takes
determination yes you need to work hard
at it it's no
quick feeding like social media whatever
you got to take time
but it's so rewarding when you invest
that time
in learning and i continue you know i
tell your
viewers keep asking questions why why
why and take the time to look for the
answers
and that's the way science works that's
amazing man
such a cool story yeah it does it takes
it takes a lot you gotta you gotta put
the time in and there's no instant
gratification with this kind of stuff
nothing that nothing that's worth
anything is
is instant that's right that's exactly
right you said that exactly right yeah
well thanks again and uh and then
hopefully we can do this again in the
[Laughter]
future